[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to chess
openings explained
tonight we are continuing the grind on
the f3 nimzo
believe it or not we are actually
nearing the end of this series
uh hopefully after tonight's lecture if
we get through it all
uh we will have covered all of the main
plans against the f3 nimzo you should
feel pretty good so far
uh about what's what we've covered uh
and
tonight of course we are wrapping up the
plans of four
c5 by black that dark squared plan that
we began talking about last week
uh i'm aiming to finish it up tonight
and like i said that's really the last
main plan against the f3 nimzo i am
going to do one or two follow-up
lectures with a lot of the sidelines and
go back through see if we missed
anything along the way
but for now let's jump into our main
line
of 4c5 of course we are
discussing the nimzo indian with the
move
for f3 by white and just to recap once
again as i introduced
uh last week we're talking about the
move for
c5 and this is an interesting way to
reply to the f3 nimso indian
because it essentially makes no attempt
to stop white from playing this break
of pawn e2 to e4 the break that white is
hoping to achieve by playing the move f3
so black gives white everything he wants
but in exchange
black is going to take a solid control
over these dark squares
and aim to target white's center while
it is perhaps a little bit overextended
uh the way i'm recommending to reply to
this is with the move d5
by far the main line and last week we
began talking about
the main line after kingside castles e4
and mostly this move d6 so i wanted to
wrap up our discussion of this main idea
because there were a couple move orders
a couple lines that i didn't actually
discuss last week
and the first one of those is going to
be if your opponent plays
rook e8 instead of the move d6
so what's the difference here well this
move
is actually a clever move order trick by
black
to prevent some of the lines that white
can choose from
so for example after d6 i'm recommending
the move 92
anyways i think it's the best move but
people have tried to move bishop d3
in the past and so after rookie 8 this
is simply an attempt to stop the move
bishop d3
from being played because now of course
this pawn
is simply hanging due to the pin on the
e
file and this bishop being interfere or
interfering with the queen
so you might see some people play rookie
eight and fortunately for us
it's not going to change too much the
remedy to this is to simply develop the
night out first
not interfere with the queen and then
white has nothing to worry about
and then here we can transpose back to
some normalcy with d6
but first in this game i wanted to take
a look at
a pretty model game by korobov against
gundava
gundava not entirely certain how to
pronounce the names as always
but i can pronounce the chess hopefully
and here gundava
tries this move of e takes d5 which is
a perfectly reasonable idea it's an idea
i had mentioned in the previous lecture
but i believe we mainly focused on
positions after the move d6
and knight g3 we had focused on
positions where black had already
committed to the move of b5
and was hoping to follow this up with
the move of a6
so what's different here well quite a
bit is different because
white's main source of counter play in
the positions with e takes and c
takes was to play the move a2 to a4 and
try to break down the light squared
pawns on the queen side
now obviously there are no light squared
pawns to break down
so that's why i wanted to start with
this because it does recap a lot of what
we
talked about last week but also there
are some nuances to understand here
especially when black doesn't go for the
immediate push
on the queen side that's why i want to
show this line while this
is the main plan for black black doesn't
necessarily have to go for this
which is going to change our plans ever
so slightly
so if black were to play something like
a6 and b5 we'll
transpose back to what we looked at last
week or the a6 line which i'm going to
talk about next
so instead we're going to take a look at
knight bd7 if black insists on not doing
anything
on the queen side for the moment and
white's just going to develop normally
with bishop e2
notably this move is still a bit better
than bishop d3 this idea of knight takes
d5
is still in the position and we'll see
that the bishop is actually perhaps
better placed on e2
in these variations why is that well the
black knight is actually going to be
coming to e5
and if you put this bishop on d3
oftentimes the downside is that you're
going to have to spend another tempo on
it to retreat the bishop back to c2
after this move 95 does come so here
black does play 95
anyways and we see king side castles by
white so when black isn't really doing
anything on the queen side it's true
that we don't have any immediate targets
on that side of the board but thankfully
for white
black isn't actually doing too much if
they aren't pushing
these queen side pawns so when black
just doesn't do
anything active on the queen side white
is free to just continue development
and castle the king sort of at your
leisure
and now in the game we do see grindelwa
go for the move a6
and sort of begin this idea of play on
the queen side
it sort of had to happen at some point
it couldn't be delayed forever
and if you don't play this move it gets
rather difficult
to continue suggesting improving moves
for black perhaps you could try bishop
d7 but it's
it's not really going to make too much
of a difference and we'll see that
white's
response would likely be the same so
against a6
what does korabov come up with well
white can actually sort of punish black
here
for not going for this queen side
counter play a little bit earlier that's
why i didn't really start with this line
because it may seem intuitive for black
to try to improve the pieces as much as
possible first to avoid immediate
counter play
but when black does that white can
generally just play this move a4
and now b5 is just going to be very
difficult to attain
and if you can't really get the move b5
through then it
does become rather difficult to uh to
find active play for black here
black tried with bishop d7 in the game
and now
it's time for white to develop this
bishop and i wanted to ask you guys
what do you think the best square for
this bishop is
and after i get your thoughts i'm going
to tell you a couple sort of principles
or rules
that you can use in this structure in
particular to decide where to actually
put this bishop but first and foremost
what seems natural
to you guys in the chat room here
where does this bishop belong
great wolf says maybe f4 seems normal in
a benoni structure
d2 has also been suggested g5 has also
been suggested
and skull says bishop e3 looks natural
so we've got the uh
we've got the full range here nobody
seems to think bishop h6 is a good move
fair enough nobody also thinks we should
leave it on c1 also fair enough
but yeah it it's not so easy to decide
right
all of these moves seem to have
their own upsides and downsides right
with bishop d2
this would be white perhaps contesting
black's bishop on this diagonal
looking to maybe offer a trade with
bishop e3
white is preemptively getting on this
slightly weakened diagonal
in front of the white king with bishop
f4 the bishop
applies a little bit of pressure to this
knight on e5 in this pawn
on d6 and from g5 the bishop pins the
knight to the queen
all of these squares seem to do
something useful right uh
so what why is one better than the rest
well we're actually going to see why in
this game so it may be counter-intuitive
but i believe
in this structure the best square for
this bishop
is actually the e3 square so
why do i say in this structure well the
rule that you can kind of follow for
developing this bishop
is if e takes d5 and c takes d5
have been inserted then e3 is usually
the correct
square and again i'll go into y a little
bit later on
but before e takes d5 and c takes d5
often times e3 is not the correct square
why is that well we'll see that as well
in the a6 line to follow
but basically e3 is the best square if
you can put the bishop there safely
the reason why it's not the best square
if these pawns are still on the board
is sometimes it can become a target if
black sort of plays their cards right
takes on c4 first and then takes on d5
it can become difficult
to deal with having this bishop on the
e3 square
but after ed5 cd5 e3 is the best square
bishop d2 uh simply doesn't do enough
trying to offer some sort of trade of
these bishops at the cost of
undeveloping your knight
is simply not going to be the right idea
in this case you're not
necessarily unpinning the knight either
so it doesn't make sense with that
regard
bishop g5 may look rather uh tempting to
try and pin the knight
but again i i think it's just a case of
this not doing enough
black is actually pretty happy to play
the move h6 i believe
when probably bishop b3 is the best move
and
those of you very familiar with the
bononi will understand that sometimes
black even considers playing a move like
g5 not saying that's going to be the
case here but i think
h6 is probably a useful move in this
situation for black
just to get a little bit of extra
control over the g5 square
so what's wrong with bishop f4 well this
move also looks natural
but this pressure simply isn't going to
be enough in this case
uh why not well because of the way that
white's knights are sort of set up in
the benoni
you'll see this bishop come to f4 and
you'll see this knight sort of route
itself
over to the c4 square you'll even see
maybe this knight come into b6 something
like this and white's play is very much
focused around pressuring this pawn
in this case this knight it's true could
come to f5 to try to pressure the d6
pawn
but for the moment it can always be
captured on that square
and this pressure just really isn't
going to be
going to be good enough here right we're
never taking on e5 because rick takes c5
is always good
and again there's no knight c4 follow-up
that's really the critical follow-up
with the bishop on f4
so all of that is to say while these
moves are
fine they're okay squares for the bishop
we're gonna see that e3
is actually the best square and again
you know i'm sort of neglecting to tell
you why
because korabov really does an excellent
job of showing why this bishop belongs
here in this game
so black follows up with the move rook
c8 which doesn't really seem super
intuitive
generally when black is trying to play
the move b5 opening up the a
file you would want to sort of contest
this file or play rook b8 to support
this push
but with black's play white has sort of
successfully prevented this idea
for the moment so what black does is
instead
tries to push the move c4 through
without playing b5 at all which is
just sort of another way of going about
things uh
now korvov plays the move king to h1
which is almost always a good idea
in the structure where you've pushed the
pawn to f3 just get your king off of
this diagonal
uh you never really have to worry about
those those tactics anymore
and it's it's a pretty nice way to move
it as well you just get the king to a
safer square
and now black does play the move c4 and
here
corb demonstrates why did we put the
bishop on e3 the square didn't really
make that much sense well it was simply
a stepping stone to put the bishop on
the d4 square
after black pushes the pawn to c4 this
is the plan
with our dark squared bishop now how
does this make any sense
well it sort of has to do with the
position of our knight
in a lot of normal winoni uh a lot of
normal benoni positions
as the chat mentioned you want the
bishop on f4 to pressure d6
and you bring the knight to c4 to sort
of work in tandem with the bishop
now that our knight is on g3 we want to
bring our bishop to d4
because we're actually more interested
in pressuring the g7 pawn in this case
and it may not seem like a lot but it's
actually how korobov
makes some some pretty nasty threats in
the game also notably
pressuring this knight on f6 is going to
be very very useful
as well uh how so well let's just take a
look
at an example line so in the game knight
g6 was played
and white plays the move queen to d2
and the idea now is to just uh allow
this queen some access into the king's
side
connect the rooks and it's it's just a
nice improving move
so here for example what would happen if
black plays the move b5
this seems to be sort of the natural
continuation of black's plan
you want to play b5 push through with b4
and here white actually has a really
nice idea
you can simply open up the a file that
white is now in control of
thanks to this rook having to vacate to
push through with c4
and now this move rook a7 actually just
makes a very very nasty threat
bishop takes f6 is the idea and this
queen is simply overworked
g takes f6 of course would be horribly
weakening so this bishop on d4
is quite clearly sort of a superstar
piece here
for white it's just a very active square
it influences both sides of the board
and makes some very concrete threats on
the king's side
so in the game of course gundam is a
strong player did not play this move b5
allowing white to have the advantage
instead they tried the move b6
simply guarding the g5 square like i
said this tends to be a useful move for
black that's why i didn't like the move
bishop g5 so much
and now white follows up with a very
nice move of pawn
to a5 and what's the idea well the idea
is now uh this uh pawn push to b5 is
sort of on hold permanently
for black black is just never really
able to get this pawn pushed through
with the pawn on a5 by the way what's
the idea on bishop takes a5 well of
course the idea is to simply capture
on f6 when once again this queen is
going to be overworked and
and the damage is sort of even worse now
on the h6 square
so a5 uh stunting black's play on the
queen
side now we see net h7 trying to step
out of the way
and here the purpose of the knight does
sort of show itself with this move
knight h5 and with this move
uh we see white taking a very firm
advantage here
uh this pawn on g7 is very very
difficult to protect
and the only way the black found to do
it is with the move pawn to f6
which is obviously not ideal and so from
here white had a very strong advantage
and korbov did go on
to win this game although of course it
was a rapid game so there was some some
more back and forth to follow
but what did black do wrong so far it's
it's a little bit
unclear to pinpoint exactly where black
went wrong because
white is sort of employing the strategy
that i really like a lot in the opening
where black's natural plan is just very
difficult
to uh to push through like everything
black did
may look strange at first but it was all
with the idea
of sort of advancing this natural plan
for example uh here it may be
it may seem strange to go bishop d7 and
rook c8 vacating the a file
but how else is black supposed to push
b5 without having c4
in first so black sort of needed this
support uh of the pawn on c4 in order to
ever even think about playing the move
b5
so we see black go for this plan
uh and then after c4 i mean what else uh
is black supposed to do here if you're
not pushing on the queen side
it's very unclear where you're going to
find the active counter play
and by the way if black sort of just
passes for the rest of the game
white is eventually going to consider
pushing with the move
f4 as you would expect in many uh benoni
style games as this
is so black must go for the immediate c4
uh and then from here perhaps knight g6
is a little bit of a strange move
uh but after knight knight g6 everything
sort of makes sense
right this bishop is applying pressure
here so black plays h6 to stop
ideas of queen g5 and then from here how
else
are you supposed to ever take this pawn
on a5 without removing this knight from
the f6 square
and the answer is you really just can't
so white
seemingly gets an advantage out of
nowhere
because black's plans were difficult to
play and that's really what i'm aiming
for
in these f3 nimzo lines
so okay what could black have done
better it's useful to talk about well
here black really has
one chance to stay in the game and that
is to understand this bishop is so
so powerful that it's actually worth it
to play the move bishop c5 which is
definitely
not what you might anticipate from the
position because this is in fact upon
sacrifice after bishop takes e5
and bishop takes c4 and white would go
up a pawn here
but black would have some very active
pieces and a lot of compensation
for the pawn alternatively white is not
really forced to do this you can also
take on c5
getting rid of the powerful dark squared
bishop and just replace this bishop on
d4 with a queen
it's still a very very strong outpost
influencing both sides of the board
and i think white is is probably doing
uh pretty well here i don't know if
white is that much better
black does have some active ideas still
in the position such as
eventually playing for an idea of b5 and
routing this knight away from
from e5 aiming for squares like f4
but i think with this powerful
centralized queen
and a mobile center white should have
absolutely no problems here at all
so what's the point of all this well the
point was to show sort of what happens
if black takes a slower approach right
all the lines that we looked at
on day one we're pretty much involving a
quick b5 because that's the most active
way for black to play
so hopefully this game gives you an idea
of how the game can sort of turn out
if black takes things a little bit more
slowly the the key ideas
this a4 move by white is super
restrictive and bishop e3 with the idea
of bishop d4 to follow
is just the best square for this dark
squared bishop after e takes d5 so
questions here
questions here
with the bishop on before it seems like
a bad bonus bad version of the benoni
for black
uh so kind of yes and no uh i would
remind you that the snake benoni exists
which is an opening where black goes
bishop f8 to d6 to c7 to a5
so maybe it's a better version of the
benoni uh depending on depending on who
you ask
that being said the benoni is still
pretty bad
uh is white not better here with e5 i
don't think e5 quite works
we can take and there is a a problem on
the e file so
just just develop here we are actually
going to look at a line that goes with
b5 here
and e5 a little bit later tonight if we
have time we actually are
not moving the fastest so we might not
have time but
with that in mind why don't we continue
on here so
before we look at this line of the
immediate b5 and e5 which i do want to
get to tonight
there is one more idea that i wish to
look at
which is rather than the immediate b5
what happens if black sort of prefaces
this move with the move of a6 it's sort
of another way
for black to uh take the position a
little bit more slowly
but the ideas do uh change just a little
bit
so let's take a look uh and here we're
going to see
the same opening moves of course c5 d5
castles e4
here we're going to look at the
immediate d6 now 92
is still the move that i recommend a6
now
by black is the move i want to talk
about so our main line was this idea of
b5 we just talked about
perhaps a waiting idea with the move
rookie 8 so what's different with the
move
of a6 well the answer is not too much
it is really all that different we're
still going to play
knight g3 this is the square i suggest
putting this knight on
in every line and then black is probably
going to follow up
with b5 so
what's the difference compared to our
main line well white
sort of has a decision to make here and
this is not the easiest decision
of all time um and that decision is
what do you want to do with this move
that black has given you
uh if we were to transpose to our main
line our quoting port transpose we
nearly transpose with the move bishop e2
uh here black's best idea is to take on
c4
when white has wasted the tempo playing
bishop e2 to c4 compared to the main
line
and black has spent that tempo pushing
this pawn to a6
while this may seem insignificant this
actually does change our main line
pretty considerably
for example our main line continues with
e takes d5 bishop takes d5
knight takes d5 queen takes d5 and
in this position previously we had the
pawn on
a7 this meant that black's only move was
queen b6
and then play could continue from there
white gets some advantage
with the idea of knight to h5 in our
main line which if you want a refresher
on that please watch last week's lecture
and here of course the difference is
rook a7 is a legal
move and this isn't necessarily
great for black or anything i think it
should be about equality
which makes sense because it's an
improvement on a line
which i do think is just strictly better
for white so
uh while this is a quality i do think
white can
try to put a little bit more pressure on
black
why is rick a7 better than queen b6 by
the way well now
uh in the queen b6 line black is never
really threatening to play bishop e6
for fear of losing the rook on a8 and
whereas in this line now bishop e6 is a
tangible threat
and for this reason knight h5 simply
loses much of its
punch in addition to that the queen is
on d8 rather than b6
which means some ideas of queen g5 are
also not available
so black is just sort of more well
equipped to deal with white's kingside
ideas
so what am i going to recommend instead
well i
sort of want to do something with this
bishop and this is sort of what
everybody wants to do in this position
that that has arrived here bishop e2
though if you want something simple if
you don't want to learn anything else
bishop e2 should get you into positions
that that we've already seen before
from the lecture uh uh last week
so what to do with this bishop well i
said that
f4 doesn't make the most sense for the
bishop in this structure
because the pressure on d6 is actually
not
the most critical however in this line
bishop f4 is the most popular move
why is that well here white is actually
pressuring d6
not with the second piece of the knight
but with the second piece of the queen
what does this mean well white is making
a very tangible threat
of opening the d file and then this
pressure on d6 does
once again become a relevant factor in
the position
with that being said i analyzed these
lines pretty deeply
and it actually turns out to be white
who's
sort of on the back foot um
with accurate play by both sides it
should work out to be a draw
but the the games i was looking at it
really seemed like white was the one
sort of fighting for it going for
crazy attacking sacrifices and finding
only moves
to give a perpetual check to black
which if you don't believe me look at uh
this position in the database there's
a couple games one in particular between
uh 2300 by the name of palacer and david
howell with the black pieces
where white did manage to fight his way
to a draw but it it wasn't
necessarily comfortable so what i'm
going to recommend
is actually playing the move bishop e3
anyways
and this is a little bit uh
you know a little bit counter-intuitive
based on what i said
in the previous line i said bishop e3 is
a great square
but it can be a little bit dangerous to
put it there
if black has not yet committed to e
takes d5
and now we're going to understand why
this position has actually only appeared
once in my database
um and in that game black played rookie
8 but that isn't very
uh very testing to be honest we are
going to look at at that continuation
but i think the most testing here is to
actually play the move bishop b7 and
this is why putting this bishop on e3
rather than on f4 might be a little bit
more
dangerous black has this idea of
pressuring this pawn on d5
that otherwise wouldn't exist if this
bishop were on f4
if this bishop were on f4 and black
tried this we would simply take the e6
pawn
and take the d6 pawn be a pawn up and go
on to win the game easily
of course but here we don't have such
luck that being said we can still take
more ideas
from last week's lecture uh because we
also faced a similar idea in last week's
lecture
of this move bishop b7 what's the
difference
well these two moves have now been
included
but this doesn't actually change all
that much
again our remedy to this is going to be
to play the move a3
bishop take c3 is going to improve
white's structure
and this move isn't really going to be
much of a problem white does
end up in in an advantageous position
after it takes take six six six and
takes and i think hold on uh takes here
and then yeah
rook b1 not bishop takes c4 and this is
what gives white the advantage making
use of this open b file that's why black
doesn't want to take on c3
because white is going to get on this
file first and it's going to be a very
useful file for example
here and then we're happy to take and
only then
capture here and white is simply better
with the active rook
uh so better for black is to drop this
bishop back
to a5 and keep the pressure up on this
knight on c3
and now there are a couple ways the
game can go i'm going to actually
recommend playing
de6 and fe6 and then c
takes b5 mainly because this is what i
recommended
last week against a very very similar
line and once again
the only difference in this position uh
compared to what we saw last week is
that bishop e3 and a6 are included
and we're going to see that it doesn't
actually change too
terribly much in the position for
example
black's only try here is to play the
move queen e7 and this is
sort of a difference to what we saw in
last week's lecture
last week black could immediately play
the move d5
and that's why we have this bishop on e3
it's sort of slowing down black's play
because now d5 of course is simply
hanging the c5 pawn
so black's play comes a little bit
slower and another advantage
for white is that we do sometimes have
the opportunity to actually capture on
a6 as well that being said black does
have
one sort of advantage compared to last
week and it's that these pieces are sort
of set up for a fork but we'll see that
the tactics work out
to uh to be okay sort of for both sides
for example d5 here
uh by the way the move for white is
bishop b2 you simply have to get castled
d5 castles now d4 seems to be winning a
piece
but once again black white has some
clever tactics
with the move b4 uh of course uh cb4 is
met with ab4 and bishop takes on d4
so black's best move is bishop back to
c7
and now white is going to sacrifice two
pieces for the rook
in order to get a ton a ton a ton of
pawns
and at the end of the day
this endgame should actually be a little
bit better
for white in my opinion uh probably this
is a draw
with good play but i think i would
honestly rather be playing with
with the rook here compared to the two
pieces especially
when uh well immediately it's two pawns
for uh two pawns in a rook for two
pieces
and i wouldn't be surprised if this c3
pawn were to fall
without too too much of a fight right
this knight is going to come back to e2
bishop e5 is playable but i'm going to
be tough to hold on at least to both of
these weaknesses
together so that's what i'm sort of
recommending here
okay so to recap what are we talking
about we're talking about this waiting
move of a6 compared to this waiting move
of rookie 8
and the answer to both in this case
well sorry rookie 8 we just go knight g3
with a6 we still go knight g3
and then after b5 now we go bishop e3
and
we get lines very very similar to our
main line of play
but with the difference of this bishop
being here
and this pawn being here which does
change some things in the lines
lastly let's see what happened in our
one game black played rookie 8 there
we saw bishop b2 by white just natural
play get developed get castled
takes on c4 was played takes on c4
takes here uh and sorry yeah so instead
of bishop b2
after rookie 8 there are some other
ideas you can go a3 still you can do
king f2 even but yet i think bishop b2
is fine
it's the simplest and now we get
similar positions to what we've seen
before but with these moves included and
again
black is doing okay here but white white
has has nothing major to worry about
either simply castles
and the game continued on from here in
an approximately
level position okay so questions on this
line
questions on this line
the computer would love an open board
with two bishops
computer says white is slightly better
in that final position we were talking
about
um okay so i don't want to spend too
much time here because
we time is short and we have a lot left
to talk about so i want to at least
introduce the main line
uh or or the the most combative line
in c5 i am gonna still claim
that this move here is the main main
variation it's sort of the most common
uh at the top level i think but the most
dangerous line
is what i want to wrap our lectures on
c5 up with
so let's take a look at it so as we've
seen before
we're going to get to this position
after d5
and now either the immediate b5 could be
played
and here we looked at the idea of b take
c4 in last week's lecture
but black can also castle and these
moves can be transposed it doesn't
change anything at all
you get to the exact same position so
regardless here we are uh in this main
position
so against rookie 8 we saw that e5 was
unplayable due to e takes d5
but actually against b5 and castles the
most combative approach by black
the main line for white is in fact a
push through with e5
and i did quite a bit of work here and i
am going to recommend
the main move uh that being said if you
decide
that this main line stuff is a little
bit too complex or you're not happy with
the final positions
then there are other options here for
white if you just
simply want to get a game i would
recommend the move knight to h3 this has
been played by some really strong people
uh el alliana has played this farouja
has played this
and white sort of avoids a lot of the
theory by playing knight to h3
not to say there isn't any theory here
either but you
you do sort of avoid going down these
tangents of this this e5 move
you avoid a lot of that that being said
when compared with the lines we were
learning
you no longer have the option to bring
this knight to g3
which is going to give you perhaps a
slightly worse version
of those lines the move knight e2
is not really going to be playable here
that's the idea
of black setup why can't we play knight
d2
because black is simply going to capture
our pawn now um
that's in comparison with lines where we
saw castles
d6 and only then b5 when we could
respond with knight g3
and have our pawn defend it this is
black's point
this is why black allows this move of e5
because
it prevents white's natural developing
plan of bringing this knight out to uh
to the e2 square
so if you do want to avoid all the
theory i think knight h3 is a great
option i think bishop g5 is also a good
option to avoid the theory bishop d2 has
also been tried
to avoid some of the theory i don't
recommend the move 92 because i think
black is better after b
takes c4 but i am recommending the move
e5 which is the main line stuff
main line stuff here
so to follow this black is going to play
the move
knight to e8 uh
what else right knight h5 unfortunately
doesn't really make much sense here
um no need to have this knight on the
rim
black actually has a very distinct plan
of bringing this knight
out to the c7 square in order to
pressure once again
white's over extended center this is
sort of the purest form
of this opening line for black just
directly going after the center
drawing it as far into black territory
as possible
and then sort of giving it the axe
that's what black wants to do we don't
necessarily have to allow it to happen
now
the natural follow-up for white is
correct here you want to play the move
f4 to can to defend your slightly over
extended center
and allow this knight to develop out
naturally behind the pawn
black should continue now with e takes
d5 black and also by the way play d6
but you will quickly transpose because e
takes d5 really should be played in this
position
so we're sticking with ed5 now cd5 d6
has to be the move here for black like i
said
white center looks really really
powerful and it would be really really
powerful
if black didn't attack it right away
with sort of everything
that black you know possibly has to
throw at it
so here knight f3 is again the natural
move and again
the correct move uh then that's the good
news for white
at least at the beginning of these lines
the the theory
is sort of the also the natural
developing moves once again let's let's
run through that quickly
we play e5 drive this knight back to e8
then we push
f4 supporting our center take back with
the pawn
and play knight f3 to control our center
once again so now we're going to take a
look
at two of the main lines and at least
i want to show one example game in a bit
of a sideline just so you get a feel for
that as well
but let's start with the main main move
here and this is the bad mood
bad news uh the main main move is the
move pawn to c4
and this is equalizing for black
i clicked through uh everything you
could possibly click through here
and with best play black is is just
going to be equalizing so
let me introduce to you some of the
various options white has to go for
and uh what i think is maybe going to be
the trickiest for black to handle
so the move a4 is the best move and is
the natural move
and this is played in almost every game
you just want to break down these queen
side pawns and this is an idea that's
not new to us we've seen this before
against a quick b5c4 in last week's
lecture
and that same idea holds true here and
now the onus is sort of on black to find
some accurate moves the move knight d7
very much should be played this is the
main move here we are gonna like
take a look at an example game later
where uh alexey shirov was playing
kramnik and kramnik chose the move
bishop g4 like i said though that's a
bit more of a sideline
97 by far is the main move
and here bishop e2 is the main move for
white and really should be played once
again
and this is maybe the first move that
that is sort of easily forgettable
so i i really do recommend you study
this line a little bit
if you you do decide you want to play
like this and not play with one of those
other options for white a little bit
earlier on
bishop v2 is actually really important
you need to introduce the threat of
castling you need to defend your king on
the e file
and you need to uh yeah you need to get
developed basically so bishop v2 super
important move
i don't think bishop d2 is as good
because then black can start opening
things up in the center
and white is going to start to get into
trouble with queen e7 when again you are
missing some defense
for your king so bishop b2 important
move bishop e2
and now black should play the move queen
b6 to stop white from castling
if white if black were to play a slower
move
let's say something like uh queen c7
black or white could very much consider
castling the king here and i think would
be a bit better
just for example castles takes takes
takes
takes takes and bishop f4
queen e7 and something like ab5 or
knight b5
and i think it's going to be white with
a slight edge
with even material and a strong d5 pawn
on the center
and the king sort of safely castled away
so that's why players with the black
pieces
are likely to play the move queen b6
just stopping king side castles
and here the lines sort of diverge once
again
you can play a takes b5 with white and
this is sort of the main line
or you can play bishop d2 with the idea
of knight takes b5
and what i'm gonna recommend is actually
sort of a strange combination
of the two because i like making things
sort of confusing for the opponent so i
like playing bishop d2 first i've
decided
now black has to play the move knight c7
to increase the pressure to the d5 pawn
this is sort of what black has to do if
black doesn't do something like this
let's say something like i don't know
it's it's hard to offer a move here for
black that isn't knight c7 but let's say
something like
a6 or knight c5 for example this is
definitely a step in the wrong direction
for black white is now just going to
take
on b5 and be significantly better
so knight c7 is sort of the idea for
black you have to apply
more pressure to the center and now
white should in fact
capture this pawn on b5 and
now is where i sort of uh got the idea
to sort of mix ideas here
knight takes b5 is generally the idea
with bishop d2
but it's not too late to play a takes b5
and i actually prefer this line a little
bit more
now why do this instead of a takes b5
immediately well
because the lines are slightly different
for black here black should
take on e5 in this case and then play
knight c7
whereas if you are playing bishop d2
first
now takes on e5 is actually a
significant mistake
because after knight c7 d6 is going to
be very very strong
when knight d5 is coming through next so
that's why i'm recommending this weird
move order
there are some very serious tricks that
black has to
has to look out for against this this
tricky looking move of bishop d2
so funny looking move order but with
good play black equalizes with knight c7
now i go back to a takes b5 and here
after de5
fe5 uh this is correct now
you can no longer really go with pawn to
d6 in these positions
uh oh so sorry rook e8 and now you can
no longer really go
with pawn to d6 because black is going
to take here
and take on b5 and be perfectly fine
getting rid of this knight before it can
ever hop to the d5 square
so rookie 8 and now the move for white
is going to be knight a4
and i know that the theory is getting
sort of long here but bear with me
this is the one long variation that you
have to know now
queen takes b5 and white has two options
if you want to continue playing the
chess game you can play king side
castles
if you want to make your opponent find a
forced
draw line then you can play the move d6
that's that's basically the option here
you can play d6 and be better
unless your opponent knows the forced
draw line or you can castle and be
equal and the game will continue so
briefly let's look at castles
after castles simply bishop takes d2 is
a good move also knight takes d5 is fine
then takes takes queen takes d5
and queen c3 and you just get some chest
position here
right white isn't really going to be
worse the c4 pawn is likely to fall
uh the e5 pawn may fall but it's going
to be risky for black to be able to take
that
and it's just going to be equality here
um
the more you look at it the more equal
it becomes
so you can castle and keep the game
going but i think d6 is sort of a better
winning try
even though there is this forced draw
variation if black is booked up
now knight e6 is playable but the fourth
draw line
goes with knight take c5 now d takes
c7 is an extra piece for white
but black has this move knight takes f3
g takes f3
and then black to move and draw here of
course
it's the most obvious move in the
position you put the queen
on g5 and white cannot escape the checks
unfortunately um so if if
i i really highly doubt your opponent is
going to find this over the board
so if they're super super super booked
up and they know this move queen g5
exists
then they're going to be able to get a
draw which
that's the way it goes if you're afraid
of that happening then you can castle
and move 17
don't play the move d6 and the game will
keep going if you want to try
to win but honestly i think it's going
to be a rare find
for somebody to have studied the f3
nimzo this deeply
from the black side and be so well
acquainted with all of these different
variations that they know this queen g5
draw
in this particular version so queen g5
and then just to show you the game ends
with queen h4 check
queen f4 check queen h4 check and queen
up for check
black uh white chant dare come to the
queen slide
due to rookie 3 check and bishop c2
check to uh to
follow when white is simply worse okay
so how did we get here
well we got here from the move king side
castles with b5 without playing d6
without playing rookie 8
this is the line where white can go e5
again if this type of stuff isn't for
you
knight h3 bishop g5 bishop d2 all
playable moves here that'll avoid
this sort of forcing stuff so e5 98 is
the only move
now f4 black takes on d5 or plays d6
doesn't matter uh because here black
takes on d5 anyways and you transpose
so takes on d5 take back d6 knight f3
now c4 and white's idea here is to
challenge these pawns with a4
black's idea is to immediately start
fighting back for the center with knight
to d7
now we must play bishop e2 defending our
king on the e file
from any queen e7 threats and
threatening to castle
black plays queen b6 preventing white
from castling king's side
we go bishop d2 increasing the pressure
on this pawn
and making this a bad move due to the
idea
of playing the move d6 to follow with
knight d5
in tow alternatively if
white plays a slower move like bishop b7
we are also very very happy to take
on b5 as well this time with the knight
so black's only path to equality is with
the move knight c7
and then we're gonna go back on our word
with bishop d2
not play knight takes b5 but a takes b5
instead and now black
equalizes with d takes e f takes e
rookie eight
now knight a4 for whites
and our idea uh that i'm recommending is
d6
when black has this crazy force draw
line or the game can
keep going with the move uh knight e6
when i do think it is close to a level
position after something like bishop b7
things get traded off the board
and you end up with just some chess
position queen f2 here for example king
h1 is also fine
and it's going to be uh going to be an
interesting chess game to to say the
least
so questions on this the the main line
of our variation
questions on this uh natural moves that
that you want sort of more explained
questions here four pawns attacking the
nimzo indian yeah kind of it's it's
similar
it's similar to the fact that you push
four pawns i guess
a bit complicated so i agree i think
this is the most complicated line
in the f3 nimzo so if this
sort of stuff scares you don't get too
worried this
i think is definitely the the most
complicated variation that you'll have
to deal with
and uh while it is very complex and it
can be a little bit intimidating
uh i do think white is is going to end
up on
at least equal and a lot of times better
uh if black is ill-prepared
all right well then let us continue on
if there are no major questions for us
here so i want to talk about
a sideline now which
black can choose instead of this move c4
so c4 is our main main line but black
doesn't necessarily have to play c4 here
the other idea
is to play this move knight c7
that being said while the c4 line i
think totally equalizes
i am yet to be convinced that knight c7
is total equality
for black i think shock mohammed yarov
who has achieved this position with
white
twice and won both of those games has
done a pretty good job of showing why
this position is not necessarily equal
so
for our ideas against knight c7 we are
going to turn to a game of shocks
this time against hau yifan and
let's see how it goes we have f3
d5 e4 and now e5 once again
98 once again f4 to defend our center
d6 this is the other move order like i
said
what black is going to transpose with e
takes d5 next though
so it takes takes we have transposed and
now rather than
c4 allowing white to play a4 with
pressure on the c4 pawn
how euphone decides to go with the less
popular option but still very much an
important line
with knight c7 and here
shock's idea is to simply do the same
thing as in the other line
which is great that makes things easy
you only learn
one idea and then you use it against
everything so
a4 still going to be the move here now
this position has actually only been
reached about 12 times
according to the database that i'm using
um
and in 10 of those games
uh how yuffan's move of bishop b7 was
was played
now the other idea that made two
appearances is this move b
takes a4 and i guess this is black's
attempt
at saying no no no you can't play a4
here i have not committed my pawn to c4
so this is you know now a playable move
of course this wouldn't be playable with
the pawn here
white would take the pawn for free and
then have a good position
but here honestly the the same ideas
that are good for white
uh in the game are gonna be good for
white here as well
uh simply bishop d3 and
white has very natural development can
castle king's side quite easily
and if you first look at the main
variation which we just did
i think you'll find that this looks a
little bit more pleasant these pawns
aren't exactly falling
we got our bishop developed we got our
king castled
and for what our a4 pawn which we're
going to take back very very easily
yeah should be good should be good so
after a4 i
simply don't believe in b takes a4
bishop b7
should be the idea for black it's the
most sensible
way to continue the game here why is
that well black
didn't waste time with c4 and the reason
for this isn't necessarily because c4 is
a weakness after a4
is because black is just trying to
immediately pressure the d5 pawn wasting
absolutely no time playing something
like c4
now what's the downside to not playing
c4 why can't black just do this stuff
immediately well the downside is
c4 turned out to be a really useful move
because it controlled
the d3 square so it's not surprising to
learn that the refutation
to black's idea is to simply put this
bishop onto the d3 square
this square that black neglected to
control
now fans of a certain type of trojan
horse
may be familiar with this type of
position and understand
that white is very seriously just
threatening now to go bishop takes h7
knight g5 and queen h5 and just win the
game
uh it's it's really that simple so
must respond with either g6 or h6
uh in both of shock's games which were
the two only two games that this
uh occurred at sort of the the top top
level uh his opponents chose the move h6
and i do think this is the better move
that being said in any game where shock
mom and darv is not playing
the move g6 was chosen uh that being
said
i do think this move is is quite simply
a little bit worse here white can take
this pawn
either with the bishop or with the pawn
or simply castle which i also think is
quite good
black continues with c4 but now bishop
e4
and these dark squared weaknesses are
really going to be telling
a little bit later on in the game and g6
also has the downside of allowing white
to have a little bit of a hook here
expect white to play something like f5
f6 would be a threat
f takes g is always going to be a threat
and this is just going to be very good
for white so i do think h6 is the better
move which makes sense
uh which uh which is why it makes sense
that it was played
both times at the top level but now
shock simply castles the king
and says all right why am i not simply
much better compared to the main line
and it's it's an excellent question uh
in the game
ho yifan tries bishop takes c3 b takes
c3
and d takes e5 i should mention that
shock's other game in this variation
was against liam uh liam lay and that
was actually a rapid game liam late
tried this move c4
but after bishop b1 uh black was still
having to deal with the threats
on this week diagonal and liam lay lost
that game very convincingly
as well so bishop takes c3 it was how
efon's choice
b takes c3 d takes e5 now
and shock finds this interesting move a
takes b5
allowing the center to collapse which is
probably not what what your first guess
would have been
for this variation right you build this
big big center
and then what you you just let it
collapse well in this case
uh yes and the reason for that is
by allowing these these diagonals these
lines to all open with the pawns getting
traded off the board
we're gonna see that it's it's going to
be white with the very very active
pieces
uh for example if black were to play the
natural looking queen takes d5
white's simply gonna follow this up with
c4
and something like bishop b2 to follow
uh perhaps first we should take the pawn
back
but now something like bishop b2 uh
these types of threats are always going
to be in the air
and white is simply much better here
much much better with black's pieces
looking a little bit entangled
as as well in the game how ifan tries
this interesting move of
e4 not allowing white to open up this
f-file for one
bishop takes c4 played in the game now
haui fun does
regain this pawn in the center and shock
simply retreats this bishop back to b1
queen c2 is coming and how iphone is is
lost
lost out of the opening against the f3
nemzo a common story a common story
uh the game did continue though with
knight d7
we do see this nice c4 idea now by shock
this pawn is uncapturable
due to queen c2 with a double threat
bishop b7 played in the game
rook a3 activates this rook laterally
knight e6 queen c2 is played knight f6
bishop b2 and it's it's quite clear here
that shock is is sort of just dominating
this game
uh knight e4 was played in the game but
this is a simply losing move rick d3 was
played now
f5 forces this knight away
knight d4 was tried but this is just a
free pawn
and the rest of this game is all very
sad and i'm going to
present it very quickly without
commentary because it was
sort of a sad affair and in here black
went ahead and resigned
so what happened this game well how you
found tries this very natural move
knight c7 and the idea of this move is
to apply
immediate pressure to white's center
rather than waste time with c4
but as we see c4 is not a waste of time
because after
number one a4 then bishop b7
which is really the the only natural
follow-up you have to
continue applying this immediate
pressure to d5 we see now that bishop d3
is
is just a very good move for white you
threaten the greek gift
black must respond to this somehow and
then simply castles
and white gets a good position so
questions here
before we call it a night uh i am gonna
do
uh one or two more lectures on the f3
nim so
following this uh i'm gonna wrap up
our talk about this move of 4c5 i think
i'm going to show maybe one or two
more examples next week along with some
some sidelines
that did not make it to the air in any
of the previous lectures so so questions
here though
questions here
michael says with the bishop on b4 g6
looks insanely weakening
and yeah i tend to agree that's i think
h6 is just a better move
which is why you know the two 2650 plus
players
both played h6 here they sort of have a
good good feeling for these things
all right well i think that is going to
do it for us tonight then thank you all
so much for watching this edition of
chess openings explained
like i said we'll be back next week i
will wrap up our conversation on
4c5 and introduce some of those fun
little sidelines that just did not make
it in any of the previous lectures
uh if you're watching live please head
on over to our twitch channel the fun is
going to continue with tactics time
and if you're watching the youtube
version or if you've just had enough
chess
for the night thank you so much for
watching that is going to do it for us
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time
you